let's continue to honor chicago um for a
tasty little bite of food news
that's right drew okay so in logan
square chicago has lots of neighborhoods
one of them is logan square
you're so ready you're oh my god we have
got an incredible ice cream spot it's
called pretty cool ice cream shop it
says it in the name it's the creation of
renowned pastry chef dana cree and guess
what dana's here with us this morning
and dana you are totally matching the
pink that is the beauty of your shop in
chicago it it just stands out on the
corner it's all pink balloons it's fun i
bet it's a real instagramable place too
it is smart social media tell us what
you're doing for halloween well my staff
dubs our shop pretty ghoul ice cream
every october
and we do
we like to go big but or little we do
little trick-or-treat pops based off of
trick-or-treat candies like
uh this year we're doing a snicker treat
but we're also really leaning into the
ice cream and doing an ice cream
sandwich complete with a bloody eyeball
in the center oh yeah
i love that you guys i've tried the
kettle corn i've done the
peanut butter potato chips they've got
funds okay drew's like drizzy it's time
to go in
oh my gosh i know okay wow this is
incredible i got the
the strawberry shortcake it's amazing oh
my goodness wow
so as you guys get to taste some of it
i'm doing rainbow rainbow chip because
i'm that gay sorry
just opened it
all right let's see if i can get it open
okay so we have s'mores here you talked
about the halloween flavors let's talk
about
something that's amazing it's that it's
a giving back component you guys do for
a cause where a dollar sold from each
pop goes to an organization we know that
in chicago we need the hope we need
grassroots organizations that are on the
streets helping our communities how are
you guys taking part in that so every
month we create a special flavor
and we donate a dollar per pop to a
local organization that's helping lift
up a little corner of our community not
a big charity with the big galas but
a small group of people dedicated to
lifting up a part of the community that
we might not otherwise know about and
this month we have a very special flavor
which is actually kind of a surprise for
you we made drew's bury more cheesecake
[Applause]
have you ever had an ice cream named
after you no whoa
we put your one of your dogs on the
cover too
is that douglas
let's see oh my gosh
[Applause]
so there's one thing on here that says
and i would love for you to talk about
this is it's supporting girls rock
chicago so drew your flavor is going to
go to girls rock can you talk about what
girls rock does
yes so girls rock chicago is an
organization for girls transgender youth
and gender expansive youth that provides
musical education
instruments and they do this really cool
band camp in the summer
and they have scholarships available and
the money that we donate to them will
help fund some of the
the musicianship that they provide for
kids who really need a boost of
self-esteem and can get that through
music
i am all about this this really speaks
to me personally
i do think that when we get girls
involved in you know
extracurricular things like sports and
music it's just so important for their
focus and their self-esteem
and you know accountability and being
able to actually work with other people
there's like literally nothing
that doesn't come out of it that isn't
positive so thank you for choosing that
you get me you know me you see me this
is such an honor and i personally want
to donate five thousand dollars
obviously
thank you
[Music]